let's talk about passion passion is the
game if you're pissed that you're
falling asleep then you're winning and
if you're not you're losing it's as
simple as that
and I am convinced with every piece of
my soul that the far majority the people
in this room do not love to death what
they do I started Wine Library TV on my
30th birthday I was driving from New
York to Jersey to the store and realized
I was only 99 percent happy that one
percent made me change my entire life if
you're not 100 percent pumped every
second if you actually are happy it's
the weekend or are pumped to go on
vacation your [ __ ] is broken there's a
dirty word that nobody ever wants to
talk about it's the dirtiest word in the
game work you have to work your [ __ ]
face/off to kill it and there is no
substitute and the only way you're going
to work 15 hours a day and pay that
sacrifice to be away from your loved
ones and travel and hustle is if you're
doing something around a subject matter
that you live and breathe and die for